it's surprising that a you know CBS
doesn't have bigger SD cards and 16 gigs
I was looking for 64 they don't have
them but that's okay this will get me
this will get me through I cost you they
have the mint the mint vanilla mint
sweet mint sweet Micky faxes good hey
you're vlogging - hello I need to
forgive me - purr oops forgot razors
what else did we forget Shampoo didn't
bring shampoo well no did you bring
toothpaste yes whole big - perfect crash
like I actually forgot to brush so
confused my receipt is a flowing in the
wind like a proud flag of purchases
this is excessive excessive
so watch me watch me sit fool watch me
watch me sir
hey judge show us the dinner me jig
napkin
No so how was five don't watch me watch
me nobody's here
jumping those girls at 90 sure they
definitely isn't I'm because the other
one down the road closes at 10 I've got
my bucks is mapped out watch me watch me
ooh okay a picture sure they're just to
spoil my stuff around drop everything
the princess can have a picture ID okay
I want the picture anymore your pigs not
getting it I have to put my foot down
my uncle's own Instagram today yet oh
wait let me take him to me root or the
non toll root non we take the Torah we
get ticket missing Wario
to the class
don't let it flash me
here does first guest up and why do we
have a stop for gas Oh cuz it was
reality it's unbelievable don't seem us
no one knows it oh snap
really great song
this is a hammer car wall I'd like a car
wash
I repeat yo shaadi yo mr. Kingston we
walked in and Jenna's like I set my
stuff down and she goes can I have that
room but yeah oh it's been there though
is it really
oh you're like better over here
include better
whose
higher what's fun
simple hair tricks using three simple
holes yay so this is so weird and crazy
I was clearly shopping on Amazon because
that's all I ever do I was looking for a
basketball and then I somehow started
looking for some hair ties and some
hairspray and some dry shampoo and then
it took me to a video that Evelina and I
did together I totally forgot about it
and all the oh my gosh this is crazy
look at our closet so for the first
thing we're gonna play with look at our
closet soon headbands personally I would
love to wear this to the gym I cannot
stand there in life anyway clearly we
made it to San Diego if you judge by our
dance party
um yeah comic-con it's here I can't wait
I'm so excited hopefully I get to see
you guys and yeah that's all good nights
I'm so sleepy so what we're gonna make
is an ice cream sandwich with ice cream
but the cook
cookie dough ice cream sandwich